foreign
welcome back y'all let's check back in
with the patreon a live stream Alabama
give us another question here's a
question from Joan I used to try to
figure out why my partner won't handle
their clutter and give them ways they
could address it but I found this isn't
appreciated nor are the recommendations
followed how do you come up with
solutions for problems that don't want
to be solved how can I save a fish from
drowning
yeah it is too often like we force our
Solutions onto people who aren't looking
for Solutions yeah and when we do that
it hardly ever works yeah and by the way
a solution for you may be the opposite
of a solution for them that's why I
bring up the fish example as a parotic
exaggeration obviously Joan is doing
this with love and her heart but all
part of it has to do with her like the
grief she feels around the other
person's clutter is her own grief it's
not the grief that he's going now you
want to map that onto his experience and
say you know what man I think you should
also be feeling no I actually feel fine
in this space like oh so this isn't a
you problem it's a a me thing right yeah
it's my expectation or just maybe we
have radically different standards and
I'll tell you that if Bex wanted to
paint our entire house pink on the
inside
I would not want that right and that
would be like oh this isn't a good fit
for us if you need our house to look
like a doll house then us living
together is a mismatch it doesn't mean
you're wrong for it but it also doesn't
mean that I'm wrong for not wanting it
so Jonah what I'm not telling you is
you're actually wrong for wanting to
clear clean up his clutter no but you
know what if I put you in the ocean zone
you might drown if I take the fish out
of the ocean to save it from drowning
I'm helping him right except I'm
actually hurting him
yeah it reminds me of this episode of
Curb Your Enthusiasm where Larry David
and his wife they don't want to go to
our friend's party and so he comes up
with this genius plan he says let's go
the day after he has the party and when
we get there and he says no no the party
was yesterday we'll pretend like we
thought it was tonight and that will
explain why we missed the party but also
will look like good people who at least
try and then we'll just leave and we'll
go out to dinner ourselves and so they
do that and he's like oh no it was
yesterday he goes but you know what
you're here now come on in we've got
some leftovers we're going to play some
games and Larry's like no no no we'll
get going we came on the wrong night and
everybody's like nope you're already
here you planned on being here you
didn't have anything else to do I'm
gonna solve your problem and you're
coming in and hanging out and they spent
the whole night together just being
absolutely miserable and that's
precisely what we do to people when we
solve problems that they don't want us
solving you know uh sometimes people
aren't looking for an answer sometimes
they're looking for an out an excuse an
escape or to simply be left alone own
and you got to have the discernment to
know that's what people want what I
would say to this question specifically
the best way you can help is to just be
curious because the problem seems to be
the presupposition that it actually is
clutter and we don't know that until he
says that it's getting in the way of
something that he wants and so I would
start with being curious hey why do you
have this stuff like what are your plans
with this what do you want to do with it
in a way that's genuine and doesn't put
him on the defense and then he might be
able to explain to you some positive
anticipated use that they have or he
might be able to identify what's getting
in the way and you might be able to help
him in a way that appeals to his purpose
not to your prescriptions yeah I mean it
sounds like you know she's really
craving some boundaries to be set up
here and the best way to ask other
people to help set boundaries with you
is by respecting their boundaries so if
you know they're in a relationship where
she's really going out of the way to
respect his boundaries but he's not well
that's a little lopsided and she can you
know feel totally justified to say hey
you know I've really gone out of my way
to respect your boundaries and would you
be willing to do the same with me now if
it's just you telling him what to do
that's a different story yeah that's an
unreasonable boundary if I all of a
sudden started putting walls up in my
bedroom my wife's gonna be like what are
you doing oh I'm just putting up some
new boundaries if you didn't consult me
about these boundaries first with our
shared space our shared life and so
boundaries aren't just so I can keep you
out boundaries are so that we can keep
in what we want to keep in and then the
excess doesn't flow in but it's only if
we have the appropriate boundaries
together
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free